the fastest path to get to where you
want to go is going straight through the
hard dip anybody who creates anything
significant has been through the dip
they went in they wanted to quit and
they made it to the other side you're
optimistic you're pumped at the
beginning but inevitably it will be
followed by the dip here's what the dip
does it creates scarcity and scarcity
creates value man I've made over 2 000
YouTube videos I've been through a lot
of the dip over the last 15 years and
hopefully that has created value because
I have a perspective a point of view an
education and so there are less people
on the other side of the dip therefore
you're more valuable right the best of
the best in any field have persevered
through the dip